why does the crow take the chosen undead
to Lord Ron Oscar speaks of a prophecy
in which the chosen undead must escape
the asylum it's easy to say that the
crow is just a meaningless method of
transport but perhaps the story is
deeper than that
goggles guard the bell of awakening bat
demons take you from sense fortress to
an Orlando and snake men are used as
guards the Lord seemed to have the
ability to make beasts do their bidding
there is one goddess in particular who
has a powerful link with crows velka in
Japanese mythology crows are messengers
from the gods
symbolizing divine intervention and
guidance on human affairs the crow takes
you to Lourdes run where you become
manipulated by the gods so if we assume
that Volker is linked to the giant crow
or is the crow we have to ask why would
she want powerful Undead to escape the
asylum Velka is the goddess of sin it's
worth noting that she doesn't have a
lord soul but is an actual goddess she
does not just punish humans she is a
great degree of influence where the gods
are concerned and the Lord's fear her
everything related to Velka and
everything that the Lords fear is locked
away in the painted world of ariamis
in the painted world there are hundreds
of crows there are the crow people the
Velka there is the equipment of valgus
partners and there are the spells used
by her order most importantly however
the painted world holds everything that
the Lords fear it holds the occult ember
and the half dragon Priscilla both of
which are lethal to the Lords so with
all this information we are left
guessing the allegiance of velka why is
she taking Undead from the asylum to
Lord run the vow of silence miracle
describes Velka as a rogue deity
suggesting she has no allegiance saved
the hunting down of sinners perhaps by
taking you to Lord run she is unleashing
you upon the gods for their sins the
chosen undead certainly is a nightmare
for any gods he encounters attacking
them relentlessly until he succeeds not
even letting death stop him I think
having someone unkillable come at you
over and over again is pretty good
punishment perhaps Volker is on
gwyndolin side Gwendolyn is the leader
of the dark moons who hunt down sinners
inside Volkers book of the guilty
gwyndolin wants to find worthy undead to
link the flame and Volk who could simply
be a part of that since she chooses
powerful undead from the asylum through
her crow
interpretation number three is your own
interpretation I can't say I'm right and
I can't say you're wrong because the
game has ever been ended and it's fun to
speculate so based on this information
do you think Volker has a hidden role in
the plot is she playing her hand from
behind the scenes
why